encore cette année le quart des colonies
québécoise d'abeilles ont été décimées
les pertes des apiculteurs ont doublé
ces dix dernières années un problème
mondial
c'est quand même une crise les gens ont
modifié leurs pratiques
ça devient moins dans ta moins
intéressant de
pour certaines faire de l'apiculture qui
voit ses news
à toronto des environnementalistes
dénoncent les ravages causés aux
abeilles et autres insectes
pollinisateurs par les néonicotinoïdes
des pesticides utilisés pour la culture
du soja et du maïs potentiellement
cancérigènes et qui paralysent le
système nerveux des insectes la
disparition des abeilles menacerait même
toute notre chaîne alimentaire
sans abeilles nous n'aurions plus que
doublé pour le pain du maïs qu'on
pourrait manger
et puis quelques autres céréales comme
le riz mais il n'y aurait plus ni de
fruits ni de légumes
ce scientifique souligne que l'italie a
imposé un moratoire complet de cinq ans
sur l'utilisation de ces pesticides et
que le taux de mortalité des abeilles
est revenue à la normale
il salue l'initiative ontarienne
d'imposer des restrictions pour réduire
de 80% l'utilisation des néonicotinoïdes
dc2 un moment donné si on veut vraiment
faire évoluer les choses il faut le
faire par la contrainte
l'ontario est la première juridiction à
agir en amérique du nord
apiculteur et environnementalistes ont
récemment écrit au gouvernement
couillard faisant appel au gouvernement
du québec tecq vives de suivre l'exemple
de l'ontario en fait pour mettre en
place des des limites sinon une
interdiction totale
l usage de ces produits chimiques nous
attendons toujours la réponse
pour sa part le gouvernement harper n'a
pas l'intention de légiférer
le ministre fédéral de l'agriculture
soutient même que les colonies
d'abeilles ont augmenté ces dernières
années tout comme la production de miel
canadien il si philippe leblanc radio
canada tantôt